hello everyone Karen warden with Phil
encourage the radio show we just
finished our wonderful radio program
with Thomas Woodrow producer on
backwards through adolescence and many
other projects and we just want to put
it out there to him what is he wrestling
with as a producer what what things are
plaguing him at this moment in his
career I think the the question we're
all sort of wrestling with in the
independent film community is you know
how can we make this sustainable you
know as great as it is that that you
know we're all making thirty thousand
dollar movies no technology there is
there to do that the you know obviously
nobody's taking fees out of those out of
those films so you know you end up just
having this sort of perpetual crop crop
of young filmmakers who are doing it for
the first time and kind of big out of
there which is just simple enthusiasm
but you know I've now I'm hopefully in
spring going in the production of my
fourth film I kind of you know and
trying to make a professional life out
of this and the question is just how is
it sustainable you know how can how can
we you know the sort of middle-class
America you know it's not been sunny I
don't think anybody is hoping to get
rich off of independent film if you do
you're sadly deluded but but just just
surviving you know and and being able to
keep doing it is it's really the
challenge and you know we're in a
different model now in terms of as I say
with these thirty thousand dollar films
you know their time was ten years ago
that the budgets of these films could be
somewhere in the you know could break
the million-dollar price point and go
into three and five and eight and nine
million dollars you know and you've got
a 10 million dollar film the the
producers to be out of that is going to
be five percent which
you know enough to actually sustain a
producer for a considerable amount of
time you know with the development of
new projects I mean you could actually
see connecting you know one project to
the next and leading leading a
reasonable lifestyle if the fee is
already in that range you know you would
also have capital at your disposal than
to develop material an option material
and so and so forth but leveraging into
that kind of a situation now is just
much more nebulous how you how you